foreign
advertising for 15 years before you
started writing can
a bit about what made you switch from
advertising to your career in writing
uh well I got fired about five or six
times from advertising jobs about every
18 months during my career I'd have to
do the math to sort of figure it out
completely but
um I sort of stumbled into advertising
by mistake and it's a complete waste of
a life so I just was desperate to get
out and
uh I never thought I really could write
a book but I finally did write a book
and then it got a couple of big advances
and I just walked out one day and like
nobody was sad to see me go
so that was my career in advertising
sure and you mentioned your first book
about How I Live Now and I won all these
incredible Awards um did you expect this
I don't think I expected anything really
I mean I
well I sent it off to my agent and she
said oh my God this book is brilliant
and I I came home and I said oh they're
so nice in publishing and I didn't
realize that actually they're not that
nice but she really liked the book so in
lots of ways I kind of got lucky you
know that the first book was a big hit
and then everyone sort of
assumes that you're good at what you do
so it's a little bit easier after that
um what was your reaction when well I
had been diagnosed with breast cancer
the week the book came out
[Music]
and so and the awards came after that so
I was in the middle of treatment and all
that kind of stuff and it was fantastic
because it meant that I didn't have to
do all the pr stuff which actually I
would have enjoyed but I didn't have the
energy to do it
um but no one really expected anything
of me and all these kind of nice reviews
kept coming in and I thought God this is
so easy why didn't I become a writer
before
and you've written for young adults and
children um what about writing for
younger audiences appeals to you and
what does it offer as an adult you say I
mean I've written for adults as well and
in fact I think in a way I'm always
writing for adults but I'm interested in
adolescence as a life stage and so
um
I'm not so much writing
for teenagers but I'm writing about that
period of life and I have a kind of
theory that adolescence lasts from about
the age of you know 11 until
you know whenever did you actually grow
up which in my generation nobody ever
grows up because baby boomers all think
they're still 25.
um but it's you know the thing about
being a teenager is you're interested in
certain questions you're interested in
who am I what am I going to do with my
life will anybody ever love me and those
are kind of questions that just sort of
continue through your life on and off
you know if you have a girlfriend you're
probably not worried about is anyone
ever going to love me but you know six
months from now when she dumps you
you might start thinking again
which I believe
in dressage yes
there well I was I was doing a lot of
horse riding because it was kind of my
dream as a child and something I was
writing books and I had a bit of extra
money and a bit of extra time so I
thought okay I'm gonna try to fulfill my
dream of riding horses and I sort of
figured it was a big expensive waste of
time but then as I
I wasn't very good at it either but as I
did it more and more and more
I started to kind of get into the lingo
of dressage I'm when they talk about
threwness they talk about a cycle of
energy that propels the horse in a way
that
is incredibly powerful so most horses
you know they just kind of plot along
but a dressage horse pulls itself up
like a ballet dancer
and um and I started to think what if
the what if the rider
was
the conscious mind and the horse was the
unconscious mind so the horse is this
big fifteen hundred pound
you know animal and you can't control it
by Brute Force you have to control it by
you know softness and making it willing
to cooperate with you and so then I
started thinking about the consciously
unconscious minds and how all that
applies to writing that's a very brief
version of my lecture on throughness and
on that topic of Consciousness one
writing I read that it was whilst
walking your dogs so you met a
baddington terrier called Mila yes and
uh your opening line for picture me gone
yeah um do everyday happenings and kind
of subconscious moments often Inspire
your writing not often enough but when
they do happen they're unbelievably
exciting and they you know they do
happen sometimes and they feel
incredibly magical when they when they
do and then you feel like something is
happening in a deep part of your brain
that you're not really in control of
um but you know what you want is for
them to happen every day and they just
don't and what can you do to try and get
yourself into that well yeah I mean I
talk about that a lot and you know it's
sort of like you know when you go to bed
and you shut your conscious mind off and
then your unconscious mind starts
telling stories and people don't even
think about how weird that is but you
know it's not dreaming about what I will
do at work tomorrow it's dreaming about
a deer in a tree and you know in a
hunter but he's not really a hunter he's
actually a fish and so there's all this
kind of symbolic storytelling that
happens in your in your unconscious
brain
and it's about trying to access that and
so you can do it when you're asleep you
can do it when you're half asleep
um you know sometimes just when you're
walking thinking about other things you
know uh it just it just happens but it's
kind of hard to predict sadly
to know whether a story is
really really really good question
um
how do you know if a story is worth
telling I mean I've dreamed
the opening line of some of my books and
there's just something about it that
that resonates that you know and I don't
usually have the story in my head I I
mean the book I read for adults was
called Jonathan Unleashed and I woke up
one morning with the line
Jonathan came home from work one day to
find the dogs talking about him and I
didn't know who Jonathan was and I
didn't know who the dogs were or whether
they were really talking to him or
whether he was just hallucinating but I
just somewhere knew that that was the
opening of a book
now whether that's complete self you
know delusion and any old line could be
the beginning of a book I don't know
and what advice would you give to
someone who wants to be a writer he's
not sure whether they have anything
important to say
I mean
I certainly didn't think I had anything
important to say at all you know you
find out by doing
um you don't know if you can paint a
picture until you actually set up the
canvas and get the paints out and it
doesn't happen overnight
um you know you have to
yeah you have to really want to do it
because it's not easy I mean working a
bank isn't easy either and working
advertising was hellish but at least you
knew if you showed up between nine and
five they would give you some money
whereas with writing you know you can
show up between nine and five every
single day for two years and no one
gives you any money so
you know I don't really have advice I
think if you feel you have to do it then
you do it
can you tell us a little bit about your
latest book The Great Garden what
inspired it and what did you learn about
yourself while writing it oh my God
um what inspired it was I sold I was at
a Book Festival in Norfolk
years ago and they did a sudden round
robin where they said oh we're raising
money for I can't remember what it was
for to keep the Book Festival going and
could you donate a character in one of
your books so what you do is you say
okay
for the highest bidder I will name a
character after you so this woman called
blank Garden
bought the character in my book whether
she ever paid the money I don't even
have any idea
and then I had to write a book with her
as the main character and then I finally
in fact it took about 10 years but I
finally wrote the book and I sent it to
her and she said oh well I'm too famous
now so I don't want you to use my name
so I changed the first name
and then she said I'd quite like you to
change the name Garden as well because
it's not very common and I just kind of
said
sorry you know
and I didn't and it turned out to be a
great name because it has all those you
know the great Garden that sounds a
little bit like circusy sounds a little
bit like Gatsby it sounds you know God I
mean there's just like lots of
resonances so in a way it was a
coincidental book
s
well I hope there is one in the future I
mean you just don't ever know really I
mean every time I'm between books I
think that's it my career is over I'm
never going to make another penny I'm
never going to write another book and
I'm kind of at that stage now
um so we'll see
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV